let's find out how Ukrainian president
vlir zalinski is feeling about the
prospects of additional us funding and
what's happening now he joins us tonight
Mr President thank you for being here
thank you for having us how did your
meetings go today what did you feel
about your meetings both with the
president and up on Capitol Hill thank
you very much first of all that I have
this invitation such tough period for us
and for the United States invitation to
United States so uh the our meeting's
been I think very constructive and I had
and uh I heard very positive voices from
both parties and it was very important
that they said that they will support
Ukraine and of course I spoke with
senators and with President Biden and
with the speaker and we SP spoke about
the details which are really on today on
the battlefield and what we need to
success story to be against Russian
attacks in Invasion to Ukraine and I
think that's it's very important not to
waste time and it very important to
support Ukraine we showed really success
on the Black Sea that really was very
difficult operation and we now created
the root grain route and Russia doesn't
have influence and we on this route
grain route and we destroyed mostly
Russian Fleet that was situated
in our Waters and near our temporary
occupied Crimea that was very good I
think that's huge result and also we
spoke about the Wagers you know on the
east of our country we destroyed
their 20,000 of the terrorists and you
know that they walked in Asia in Africa
and in Ukraine and in Syria so I think
that it was so difficult for us to do it
but but what is I think the most
important thing to understand what's
going on that Russia didn't occupied any
Village any Ukrainian Village during
this
year on Capitol Hill the hold up right
now is about immigration reform our
immigration border security for
Republicans did you urge the president
to to try to cut a DE
on this to get this funding through
really Brad I'm so s i I know that that
you have your own challenges and
domestic problems and they're huge I'm
sure but I think that United States is a
great country which manage the conflicts
problems I mean managing how to to get
success how to stop Wars in all the
world and I think in this
uh in this domestic challenge I think
you really your people they don't need
my my opinion that's really I think
so so when you push back you talk about
how urgent the need is yeah and do you
think Putin would
stop if you don't get this
funding would he make a deal would you
make a deal you know what I said what I
said to Mr Speaker today that was our
first meeting I I said to him that
decision in
December about support decision in
January decision in
February it's not the big you know the
big difference between
it it's not about financing it's about
the morality the
most problem the biggest
problem when you don't support Ukraine
yeah that people on the front line
families which are waiting for their
Heroes at home that they think that the
United States doesn't support Ukraine
and that Ukraine is
alone yes defending our common values
for United States and Europe that is the
problem to kick our morality it was at
the very beginning of the war really
we've been alone and we are very happy
and thankful to America people that then
you supported us but we've been alone
and of course people afraid to be again
alone but you have to know that even
even if we'll be we will stand and fight
last thing Mr President there are
critics who say that you've tried to
consolidate power uh headlines that the
Orthodox leader in keev under house
arrest that you Consolidated Ukraine's
TV Outlets that you ruled out holding
elections next spring um calling for
Unity but then the mayor of keev says
that you're turning it into
authoritarian State how do you deal with
that criticism what do you say to
critics who are saying
that I say such person from government
or Mayors think about the war think
about how to defend our people don't
travel through the world each day travel
to the front line ask people ask ask
soldiers what they need do this not
build roads for today don't do it spend
all your money to the weapon to the
drones to the society to the pensions
and Etc and don't cry because you're
leaders and that's it that's why that's
why we are and that's why we stay
because mostly people people are not
crying people stay and fight against
Putin and we don't have any enemies in
in our country we can't have and can't
have time for this and we don't have it
we have only one enemy this is Putin and
that's it but you'll stand from
democracy going forward yes of course
and of course because we are really
defending democracy and we are really
defending Freedom Mr President we
appreciate your time and we'll continue
to follow the war thank you so much hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to sub
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now